today on our show now sometimes people
who are very good at one thing in life
happen to like other things in life man
you could be a genius at one thing and
be a fan of something else and today's
show we got a guest who is a genius of
music but he's a way [ __ ] bigger fan
of this world a Batman than he is of the
notes and stuff like that and I'm
talking about the one the only Chris
Daughtry Chris Daughtry here to talk
about his love of Batman his comic book
work that he's got coming up man as well
as you were at the Bob King ceremony was
it I did come on tell us about story
time Chris Daughtry this week right now
on fat man Batman starting right now
we're starting on this this [ __ ] I heard
hey man hey fat man about malkovich
birthmark guard and look Chris
Daughtry's yellows with us now for those
of you who are like Chris Daughtry Chris
Daughtry is a musician Fox there yeah
sometimes people we have people that's
the point of this this episode Manson
here's somebody who's kind of real-life
that's what he [ __ ] does for a living
and [ __ ] like that in front of tens of
thousands just stand under really
awesome lighting like give you some
moistures and dirt and you've got that
that's his look he likes to do that he's
like give me some sweats moistures dirt
that's how it likes to be shot that's
shot of you did he tell you to spread
dirt all over you know he's got a guy
that goes was his name what's the dude's
name cuz he say his name on time like
any crisp or something like that and the
dude would come over and put [ __ ]
dirt they gonna look like I spent all
night at Hoboken let's try that um all
right so dr. Eman is legit he's got a
real [ __ ] job and [ __ ] and yet still
I don't know if it's a real job hey do
they remember well yeah we don't or a
couple contestants who are still in
doing what gene : bleaching Louise Jean
it was cool because I feel like I've had
enough years under the belt to actually
know what I'm talking about you know as
opposed to like yeah I'm doing shows for
more people than you but ten years that
would work on that was your internship
where it's like I'm doing
I grew up 10 years you know under the
belt now and we just put out our
greatest hits album your greatest hits
yeah I was kind of worried about that
when they said oh yeah we're gonna put
one out and I was like does that mean
we're done are you guys saying you've
written the best [ __ ] you've ever gonna
write you're never gonna do it again so
we're gonna sell it again like tenure in
the music it's a nice intermission so
now we're working on album 5 I'm sitting
here looking at my face looks weird
because I went and got drilled on right
before it light we're not the root canal
and then some crowns try it and then I'm
going back for my girl next week but
I've done that and when they [ __ ] they
[ __ ] your mouth up you know I don't know
if I'm coming out of breathe diamond
grill yeah you're getting room I'm
getting a word in my teeth like he was
like I could hear [ __ ] I did they can
burn a [ __ ] something into it like
indented or or stained like a cap and
crown so what he took was like when you
burn wood I think it was like that it
was like a soldering iron or something
like that but you can see it if you look
from say I was on this earth it says
Smaug I'm [ __ ] not Podesta's like
mommy right 70 mm yeah man like a map
and he was like honor that much present
was no weirder of my discipline
all right so so yeah it was super numb
and then on the way out I guy yeah I
can't contain the excitement do is I
just saved a lot of lives today by
meeting Kevin Bacon I change lives I
don't know if I saved him but I change
lives by at least five degrees right yet
I know about but now you're one degree
that means I'm one degree of Kevin Bacon
now because you seem like you just got
changed I'm done this is a special
episode I'm gonna put on my glitter
seats now did you breach that boy I'm
gonna take a break man like back in the
sixth season their first album was
called
Greatest Hits by that man run DMC we're
like I'm the king of rock there's been
hiring really why you believe it after
they say by the end of the song you're
like it was a [ __ ] true yeah do you
know the power let's speak that into it
alright so there's a long all this long
way of saying that Daughtry has a real
job in shift but his passion in life is
the same [ __ ] that we're all passionate
about go to a three-shot of course he
loves the titular name of the show man
not the fat man bad Batman fan you've
heard it before we've got him on the
podcast fat man I'm Batman
a couple of years back but let's catch
up what you've been doing and I've been
touring the real world you're always
playing music are you home for a little
bit man well I live here now so which
makes working home a little more
consolidated and oddly enough a little
tougher whatever because you have real
life okay so I gotta kids go
you know you got a everything revolves
otherwise you know before I was coming
out here for three or four weeks and I
wake up when I want to I had to so for
that but I'm staying like busier than
ever but being out here allows you
access to access meaning this without
having to take a red-eye back and forth
where were you originally Thanks uh yeah
Charlotte Hulu from Charlotte back in
July and how do you like it
I mean I love the I'm not a big fan of
where we are in Hollywood right but we
want to be out and more calm quiet areas
the suburbs with even like a little plot
a yard would be fun right now we have no
grass nothing to do like you did say
deck yeah yeah it is it's cool being out
here I will say this because you get
access to things you get to go to shoot
you I get to come here and do this
coming here is not really about having
to go in Italy and put together
schedules right palm up you just bombed
up to the Bob Kane thing yeah I don't
know Warner Brothers likes me I guess
and all my friends at DC they're always
throwing my name and the this is going
on in by him this is going on giving
that you know whatever which is like I
don't think I would ever imagine that as
a teenager like DC is gonna be just
sending you [ __ ] sitting right there
would that to me waiting for them they
were bringing me the keys that's a
ballet okay so wait where is this that's
uh right across from the Chinese Theatre
Oh Hollywood Boulevard so you live like
close to Chinese yeah we're all like
LaBrea down the wait so you're not far
from 94 I'm up LaBrea look straight up
nice little show has devolved
it's like you just go up there over
Laurel yeah okay
I'm not - no but I'm saying like maybe
I'll just come watchdog late your house
all right so you went to put that
picture back up you went to the Bob Kane
thing they had a big see I'm sporting
that the batfleck Affleck shirt brown
supporter from day one was he there no
he was supposed to be but they ended up
getting some dude dressed up as Batman
instead because he just film hogging the
boulevard just watch these guys I don't
know he he looked pretty good it wasn't
he wasn't Affleck but could you imagine
though if they were like he's like
alright I'll make time in my schedule to
come out to the [ __ ] thing and
they're like put this Batman yeah it was
brief but I think I think a buddy of
mine took a picture of the back of my
head and slightly smiling at me so it
looks like we're kind of like catching
up on old times
you've been closer to Ben Affleck than
I've been in years
what was the ceremony like for Bob Kane
even though benefit was cool his wife
was their guy to meet his wife she was
in the movies right she was gossip girl
she was gossip Gerty that's right none
of my Bement yeah
but yes she was I mean she looked way
younger than I imagined the numbers show
you know I was like wow alright but now
I'm not like I look young like I just
got a bunch of work done no like she
aged not good living yeah seven out here
was like like Jefferson Stanley's 93 run
upstairs yeah you look stay 93 joan is
why she don't look like the hurry
they're like living out here with
superhero money it's been good for a lot
of people I think we look through that
picture right of Frank Miller and
Stanley together and at a Barnes & Noble
signing one of those dudes just 30 years
older than the other one yeah it's hard
to tell them living in California you go
these premieres and you every all the
ones I've been to he's there like the
Ant Man or Avengers or whatever and
every everybody else is like go home
that dude has got way more energy than
any of us piracy he's like he's been an
ambassador for Batman that's right it's
true he still plays in the DC pack
created spider-man all right man so what
else happened at the ceremony what
happened Jim Lee spoke Jack spoke Zack
Snyder got Zack Snyder spoke and someone
from the city on behalf of the city or
whatever
but it was cool man I mean I'd it was
cool to be a part of the induction of
the guy who made the guy that basically
is you know a huge part of my life right
I'd be like going to Walt Disney I just
sounded like I was talking about Jesus
you were saved
yeah by the bat um all right so that was
pretty cool was that same out of bed
okay he's got a jaw sri original right
singing and [ __ ] like something great on
that show like what did they do on
American Idol is it numbers no they
didn't do numbers they would either rip
you apart or talk yeah that's a [ __ ]
dog yeah yeah so that's what happy
that or you know that was self-indulgent
or do that better
next up is every moment where somebody
says something and inside you were like
no wasn't like you could disagree can
yeah yeah there was there was a moat the
Queen I had to do queenly so I got to
actually perform with Queen - you know
the great American Freddie Mercury but I
was there with Brian May and he's saying
that you're the first person is saying
this song since Freddie he never even
sang this live I don't even know if
that's how he talks but I did this song
called an innuendo which was like one of
them deep cuts it was only like the
anthology and it was the one that's I
didn't want to do like the ones I heard
over and over again and and you know
Simon was like why wouldn't you pick
like under pressure or something that
you know people know like it but it was
probably looking back with my favorite
performance of the show because it
actually had some feeling to it and it
wasn't I wasn't jaded by the song so it
wasn't like oh it's cover song yeah like
it's such a dude because it was so like
underground or or unless you're a
die-hard Queen fan then it was like hey
that's Chris doing whatever that sounds
like some he do yeah
alright so the people of DC liked you
enough for the you did a cover for right
we it all started with all roads lead to
Jim as they usually do Dodger here draws
man it's unfortunate man when somebody
has more than one [ __ ] Talent like
your singer and should end there but no
we could [ __ ] draw as well and he
gets to exploit that that's a good thing
about if you get any notoriety and doing
something it opens doors to do the
things you want to do
career has been about like I don't know
or something I'm all about the back door
film got me through to a house and then
I'm all about jumping to the back doors
and trying to do all the things like
giving a shot even if you're not [ __ ]
good at it who gives a [ __ ] like try
those things that you've always loved
Chris is actually [ __ ] good at
drawing give us a three shot and he
teamed up with Jim Lee man and did yeah
that was my first art gallery at
comic-con not last year but the year
before so those are your pieces yeah
they're all I I did them on my iPad
there were my first like digital pieces
the flash and dark side I saw the dark
side and and he it was cool because he
wasn't like therefore he showed up as
like almost like a fan to support it was
a minute and that was also my first iPad
drawing no and I can't ever recreate
that again because I was using as a
rubber knit I have no clue that this is
diverse drugs down the rubber stylus
yeah I use a tablet normally not only
the Wacom but the cover
so anyway Jim bouncing all over the
place Jim we became friends like we
talked about before and he kind of in a
indirect way started becoming a mentor
like I would send him as some of them
work at all I'm not asking and anything
other than just showing him keeping him
up to date and he'll send me like these
Corrections on remember your vanishing
points you know we're bashing points
where where everything goes in the
picture like you can't have an elbow
going that way if if he's eight facing
this way they're both that perspective
perspective you know just things that
you don't really that at least someone
who doesn't do it every day it doesn't
really think about it's one of those
things really like oh there's
terminology yeah I got to know that was
called but yeah
we go back go back one he's taking me to
school so this is your pencils there's
their original pencils are gorgeous and
I'd done a thank you
I'd done likely really nice I was
planning on doing like a backdrop that
was gonna be all kind of silhouetted out
with a few highlights but then when I
sent it to Jim who inked it he decided
more of an environment because of how
close up
they were the buildings wouldn't have
been a silhouette so that's Lee's thanks
now jinx she destroyed my buildings
[ __ ] steal what in so wait he took
liberties in creating he warned me he
said don't yes I warn you I'm gonna
break your heart basically he goes if
I'm inking it I tell this everybody even
Neal Adams he even told me that that I I
make changes that's what I do that's so
don't expect exactly [ __ ] Gimli
there's yes you don't I so you're
calling Claire Alex and Claire is done
actually all the pieces that I've had
colored Alex his color for me I believe
you met a buddy of mine and and when you
were in Australia mm-hmm
Jamie he had done another bald he's not
good at play he doesn't but he draws he
drew this joker these pencils and I saw
it on Instagram I was like do I make it
just for practice so I ain't it
digitally and I took complete Liberty
you sent me this is I got rid of the
hair and shaved it all the sides and if
you look at the color mmm
I had Sinclair do a little you guys oom
I don't know if you can zoom in on there
from but did a blood line down the from
the card hmm oh yeah I'm little
The Watchmen their smiling faces on
there oh let's check it out there's a
little blood so that was your gym leader
then were like that when I [ __ ] add
well look at I don't know if the pencils
are up there but you got his pants on I
went I just completely redid it oh my
god you really did kind of use them as a
template you're the [ __ ] tracer this
time I died go back to the inks Wow
you go back to pencils maybe that [ __ ]
yeah you made Wow there's parts of what
he did with the face said oh yeah you
did [ __ ] it I'm really sorry
way more happier with and I feel like a
what a little heavy on the shadows who
took liberties first you with his
jointer generally with yours me with Jim
Lee's like I'm gonna change it yeah damn
it well no dude this is a loose sketch
like don't have fun they'll be married
to the line so I'm just saying so can
you go back for the people who didn't
play the home game how did you first
meet Jim MySpace first of all when I was
on American Idol this was like the the
the birth of technology because I didn't
even have a cell phone then or I'd just
gotten a cell phone and have a laptop I
didn't I don't think I even had an email
address but I never used it there were
no picture phones or smartphones or
anything like that so social media the
only thing at the time I think was
myspace I don't know if Facebook existed
that well I don't know but it's not
publicly I'm sure but there was no
Twitter there was no no that and we were
we were actually made to not have social
sites as contestants yeah because they
thought that was like unfair advantage
and so if you were if you had a band you
can't be on the website but bone we get
on these l5 forums you guys I'm gonna
so I have a myspace kind of created by
the label for the band and I didn't even
know how to login and I just looked for
it on there cuz I was at home I was off
to her and I was like looking at hush
that's like man I kind of got the itch
to start draw it again I was like I
wonder if in this day and age if I could
reach out knowing that maybe he knows
who I am maybe he won't just cause some
jackass here on American Idol
and so I sent him a direct message and
he hits me back
he's on myspace too so I'm as outdated
as he was oh yeah and we we traded info
and we started hanging out and and I as
long as I've known him that's been I
don't know I was like Elite so I still
kind of geek out around him because the
dude is the guy that made me want to do
comics and make me not want to because I
was like oh no we're gonna be that good
so why even try but he's gonna be the
first guy to tell you like don't ever
stop no no all that he thought was
better than him
so we did him better we did a piece for
the we can be heroes campaign that was
our first kind of collaboration and and
we were hanging out that I believe at
the Halloween party and he was saying
would you be interested in doing a
variant cover and I was like bro I've
been waiting for you to ask me fighting
were [ __ ] friends I mean I went to
MySpace looking for Jim but um and he
said it's gonna be an promotion or in
kind of coinciding with the promotion of
Batman vs Superman and they're gonna
have a bunch of artists on different
books
I was thinking they're gonna get me like
Detective Comics or even something less
known than that they gave me Batman
number 50 mm-hmm
that he was originally listed as
penciling and they put me on it so
special so I'm like my first cover is
not only with you know Inc by Jim Lee
the guy who that I want to be when I
grow up and and through that man yeah
the Batman title and it's obviously
Superman two biggest characters and I
guess arguably two biggest characters
Mickey Mouse and Mickey Mouse like
exactly your corporate cons yeah there
and it's for you know that may have a
Superman and it was a there's kind of a
long process for me because you know
someone like Jim he's ain't he's
penciling a page a day right he's took
me like eight weeks maybe a little less
but there was a lot of 2:00 a.m. phone
calls that Jim going dude
why is this not looking right became a
question you were like oh my god I'm
[ __ ] though what I do I need coaching
it I lost like six pounds in a week I'm
like a dude with two jobs I was
recording in the studio going to
meetings about this TV show or play I'm
doing huh
and then drawing at night going to bed
at three repeat and it was just I had
barely made the deadline and there was
one of those moments really like well I
wanted this this was like something that
I wanted to do when I was five years old
I didn't realize it was gonna be the
character that made me want to draw like
you know what I mean it was all like I
hit the lottery and next step is I could
die without drawing anything and I'm I'm
good I did that [ __ ] but I'm gonna
throw it out there it's not enough to
draw [ __ ] cover now you've done a
cover you got to do the guts you got to
twenty pages
ya know you want you know I don't
panelist you don't know what scares the
[ __ ] out I know but you could do like
remember when it was a draw Medina
like this one page one palpations Death
of Superman is yeah you just do 2020 -
pages with Jenny no please because would
Inc you Jeff I wouldn't wrote a book
where I want to say like five or six
pages took place during a blackout and
black box black box black box box black
box this just word balloons over black
CC was gonna have a month of blackout
every but the other thing is you know
it's the variant to kapu low and and
Snyder which it is my favorite storyline
alle right now the cupolas a good friend
of mine as well and I'm kind of I'm his
become his on his second best is the
vice-president of his cover I'm good I'm
giving him the you know just case you
don't like this one maybe you like this
whatever will give you a few but it's
it's a it's kind of surreal what's the
play we were talking about was the play
the passion for Fox yeah
modern retelling story with Tyler Perry
being the narrator slash co-host it's in
New Orleans
I'm Judas doing there's a live my mom
units it's a live musical all the songs
or or modern they're not like Christian
so I when they first approached me the
guy who produced that Adam Anders who
produced like the Rock of Ages
soundtrack newly he's producing a
co-founder of the of the the play and
they were doing in Holland they've been
doing in Holland for years predominantly
atheist country and like fifty thousand
people show out every year and it's all
modern like modern attire there's no
bearded long-haired Jesus wearing
flip-flops you know my dudes hop the
guy's a good-looking dude he's a gin
Carlos Cannella from telling
mmm looks like Ricky Martin and and
Chris Evans got together and made
captain latin america judas judas really
yeah now you act much I've been one back
everything I'm doing now is all bucket
list that door from music music was a
Rahman's music came way late in the game
for me like I didn't pick up a guitar
until I was 16 and right that's not late
in the game for a lot of well I Lou I
grew up in a time where I felt like my
high school I need to know what I'm
gonna do so at the age of five I'm gonna
be a famous artist but that's what I'm
gonna be then I would be an actor I
would be you know an action of these or
whatever would be a superhero I don't
know what does it fill out in order for
me to get famous artist on my form
yeah whatever that degree or whatever
credits I need give me one takes in
classes go ahead tell me not so much
with the math yeah you reverse
engineered your way went to the
childhood mouse well it got to the point
where after touring for so long I was
like what do I really want to do right
now I don't want to start drawing again
I started you know getting supplies and
you know messing around and and I was
like I want to move to LA so I can start
because I'm I was doing the
back-and-forth thing for awhile I got
cast on a pilot called Studio City
with Heather Graham and Eric McCormack
mm-hmm and I was just kind of douchey
pop star drug addict that bought drugs
from Eric McCormick's character he was a
songwriter mm-hmm but he used the
meetings to sell the weed or whatever he
was selling so I would do coke I don't
even know if I'm supposed to tell this
cuz I didn't get picked up but
Christopher an off road at Sena hammer
huh Marie
hammering from the directs Empire
directed at know this huge beach scene
while I'm out like with all these
dancers and I'm like shooting a music
video they had helicopters over shooting
footage you I'm a big-budget this and
that that fell through and and so I was
doing a lot of the back-and-forth of
meetings meeting with like casting for
Walking Dead and other stuff and it was
like when I'm not on tour the last thing
I want to be doing is traveling from
coast to coast so we moved out here and
then I got an offer to play Judas and I
was like I don't know if I want to do
this so eight I don't want to do
something so polarizing and overtly
Christian because there's enough of them
out there that give it a bad name anyway
and despite what I believe I was like I
don't want to be looked into and it's I
don't know how it's gotta be taken right
and then when he whenever like Daughtry
loves Christ yeah I just didn't know how
the whole thing was gonna be portrayed
right and a and B I wasn't really
interested in doing musical right I
wanted to separate the jobs right and so
when I had the meeting with Adam and he
told me how they were going to do it and
they they were telling me some of the
songs they had in mind I was like okay I
kind of see and then they showed me some
footage of the Holliman that's pretty
awesome and I mean we've done some
rehearsals so far in New Orleans it's
all like on location all in the city and
it's gonna be on television
like that's their following yeah and
it's called why the passion so I guess
is it for this next stage no it's at
March 20th it's about to happen
yeah the four used to fly back out at 17
so you've been rehearsing all this time
and on the 7th 17th we're what they we
it's only 20th well you know this
happens like live everywhere
yeah nervous yeah because it's one thing
to sing and it's kind of weird to say
this but you make weird faces when
you're saying anyway dude well just in
general yeah you're not thinking about
do you have to know you just perform in
a song you're not really thinking about
it why does your butt ladies go weird
like does it help push out up and won't
ask John they're control when you're
acting you still have to tell the story
with your emotions right so it can't
just be you're singing a song right
going for it it's got to be like I'm
sitting here thinking about Hugh Jackman
and lame is like and how but like I
forgot he was singing it was such a
powerful visual I forgot Russell Crowe
saying because he really talking a lot
there was serious auto-tune Crowe I've
been studying Hamilton Hamilton now
seems like the Bible thing oh dude I
want to see it [ __ ] crazy good like
it's one of them yeah especially now I'm
not a musician I'm a writer and I still
walked out going [ __ ] cuz I know I'll
never do a Hamill called Hamilton some
Broadway musical right now it's like the
hardest I've never seen a Broadway play
this is the one to start with and then
you'll never have to go to another
because they'll have to except for maybe
Book of Mormon which is genius go see
what everybody oh you gotta see these
two plays are [ __ ] phenomenal but but
Hamilton does something electric they
take history and make it interesting we
wrap with there's no spoken dialogue
it's all [ __ ] performed it's it
transcends musical theatre amazing so
[ __ ] good so like no gather they're
gone no it's totally okay you walk out
going
I gotta up my game even if that's not
your game I don't [ __ ] make musicals
but I walked out then I get up my game
like it's crazy
whatever that game is
I became a far better masturbator after
I tried the stranger all right so wait
now you've been around a little BBS
action have you seen it I have not have
you not yet I'm supposed to see the edge
soon yeah I've heard
I mean I'm hearing all the stuff you
guys are hearing about everyone's scared
that it's I'm not scared I'm not I'm
[ __ ] everything I've seen if it that
complex of a story that means they're
actually thinking about how to connect
the dots and make it work for future
movies and covering their bases before
they have to cover them later yeah I
mean no I'm not [ __ ] worried I've
seen some people no no no no I'm so
there man like that I may be worried try
all those Charlie have no problem with
nasty links beer and he grows a beard
and he's just a like a good old boy like
that's the Superman that I remember
reading in the dan Jergens books back in
the 90s and grew his hair out and you
just just a huge dude working on a farm
you dock here come tonight
yeah and then you take someone who grows
up in the south whether you're an alien
or not I don't know I've never met an
alien to grow up in South X all right
as far as I know but but yeah I think
they're gonna have that character to
them because that's what they were
raised around so everyone I mean
obviously everyone's bitching about the
destruction but turns out you just learn
how to fly like three hours ago and they
also give a dude a break he can fly
totally they seem to be doubling down on
suction though you know that seems to be
a big part of like remember all the
destruction made Batman mad and now he's
back but even the billboards dudes like
I passed a bill it's all destruction it
looks there's an image tiny image of
them in the middle going like yes it is
a great shot the whole billboard is
building shattering Arnage oh it's like
[ __ ] nuts they're like yeah we know
but who cares selling building like I
see all those images I'm like take all
my money take all the money here have it
I know my kids need to go to school but
I've seen every trailer eight moves like
the world a cinema all I could think is
that dude is dead the creep is dead
where's just like BAM
Mima kill him he's dead yeah guys know
but he's not that's the beauty I think
he's not dead because Batman is so
lethal yet precise that he can take you
to death's door and just leave you there
it's Lobby just means the cripples and
no [ __ ] permanent damage but no death
if you go back to the a you know a
Batman how many people died in just in
just be in their returns like the big
[ __ ] circus guy attacks I'm like
certainly Batman tries to punch him he
doesn't react and then he looks down
he's got a [ __ ] bomb in his pants
away a writer out of church generally
just he put the bomb on him did his dick
it was a dick bomb and he blew my half
dick my dick move em in by her about
something this crazy
get to live to know what he's missing
that's true
where I was in Canada and they told me
they like there I guess mining country
they said there was a dude who put
blasting caps like blasting caps are how
they yeah low shows the aggression comes
bad put it in his mouth
hooks it up to car battery and [ __ ]
like the top of his head was it a
science experiment I think it was I
don't want to be bad I was gone his
curve through that trouble that is seems
like there are a lot of better ways
quietly film it the only reason to do so
oh yeah asking if that was his goal tip
like I'm not gonna live to see this but
I bet it looks interesting caps and a
gun in Canada but it's like don't the
blasting caps kill you anyway
mouths yeah why would you leech into
your system wouldn't blow immediately
you need a musician
oh there's castles that is depressing
myself that was somebody told me I'm
like you can't alright I'm not trying to
be insensitive but you gotta admit
that's a pretty interesting way to go
yeah yeah it can't be the elephant in
the room I wasn't trying to be like you
gotta film that stuff when it is don't
do that kids near your daughter II don't
do that yeah it gets better guys yeah he
knows look at this [ __ ] dude go back
to the single of them look at this guy
[ __ ] rock star for chrissakes
um there it is folks for fat man Batman
Kevin Smith Mark Barnard and this guy's
Chris Chris come back to the fat cave
next episode same bat-time same
bat-channel
yeah you do Beckham slash Kevin Smith I
almost forgot it
bad place
hey Nance me Kevin Smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe every time you
click that you save a baby kitten from
murder